I mean obviously right now you can't
miss it it's everywhere it's in the
newspapers it's on Instagram it's
everywhere you look all these moments
and and the patients and articles about
what's going on with the immigration
crisis and families being ripped apart
and why and people purl and people
against it so as a Latina it's really
easy to see those things and see
yourself it's really easy to see a
little girl crying for her dad and see
me all those things were happening at
the same time so I told the director
that I wanted to do something that was
viscerally connected to that
[Music]
when your
I feel what you feel
[Music]
even if I'm not American it's very easy
for me to empathize and if anybody would
ever say well you're Canadian how to rap
it's easy for you to speak on it because
you're outside of it and you're not in
it but there's a quote that that my
managers told me was because I was
explaining like my apprehension of going
and he was everything and he was like
well if only GU oppressed do the
fighting for change nothing changes the
oppressed can't be the ones fighting for
change it has to do it has a lot to do
with with Riley has a lot to do with
life and death and where we go and
switching switching the identity of both
so how are love and death I guess how
love cannot such a positive connotation
and death can have such a negative one
but in reality if you look at it it's
reverse because the day you find the
love of your life is the day you find
the person who's gonna hurt you the most
and whether they intend to or not
because if you're lucky enough to make
it till you're 80 that's blessed maybe
and lucky enough to make it to near 80
with like pure love that's a blessing
it's one of two endings oh you guys are
together you fall in love and then you
break up when you're young or you
actually make it and then you past it
you have to say goodbye anew because
someone's gonna die for